so I live in New York and there's this
Occupy Wall Street activity happening I
actually haven't been down there yet but
I've been following it a fair amount and
one of the main things are talking about
a student debt and you see these photos
of people who say you know I'm a hundred
thousand dollars in debt and I don't
have a job this is a really big issue
right now the average student graduates
with 23 thousand dollars in debt that's
a lot of debt for a 22 year old and if
you combine that with not having a job
that leads to a toxic situation student
loan debt is the only form of debt that
is not dischargeable in bankruptcy which
means it is a very very dangerous and
risky kind of debt it's frightening that
we encourage young people often when
they're not even legal adults yet and
they can't legally vote they can't
legally they can't join the military
they can't legally buy a pack of
cigarettes or a beer they can't do any
of that stuff but it's fine if they want
to sign their name off to a hundred
thousand dollars in student debt which
they will not be able to get out of once
they graduate if they can't pay it and
so what you're finding now is a lot of
young people who are in significant
amounts of debt twenty-three thousand
fifty thousand a hundred thousand and
who are depending on getting a good job
to be able to pay that debt off instead
what they found is a job at starbucks if
they're lucky that's even hard to get
these days and there's lines outside of
starbucks whenever they have a career
fair they're making seven dollars an
hour ten fifteen twenty dollars an hour
they've got to pay off a hundred
thousand dollars in debt and a lot of
these young people are defaulting and
quite frankly the salesman of higher
education are not warning their
customers their marks if you will about
this risk all they say is here's the
rosy picture you get if you get our ba
degree if you get our law degree if you
get our MBA here's all the wonderful
things that are likely to happen to you
they don't talk about the other side and
here's the risk that you might be in the
hole for 100 grand that you can't pay
off because you don't have a job and the
compound interest is spiraling upward to
not talk about those risks
borders on fraud and it is certainly
unethical that these people are selling
this form of higher education and not
talking about these very very
significant and serious risks